Speaker 1: Rudy Giuliani now admits that he did
the massive dumps, the the jokes right themselves
at this point in time, like, how can I add
anything? And I'll be completely upfront.
This is just comedic insanity, period. There is
no credibility to Rudy Giuliani at this point.
There is no I mean, the guy is as
backwards as anybody we've seen
affiliated with American politics in the last many
years. Rudy Giuliani went on Newsmax and he told
Eric BOLLING he did the big dump. And for those
of you who have been following this entire massive
dumps storyline for the last couple of years,
this will be particularly odd. Check this out.
Speaker 3: So here that they're saying
things like there's going to be a big
dump in and there was a big dump. I put
out the big dump to the New York Post.
Speaker 1: Oh, guys, i, i, i can't do it
any longer. I just can't do it. If you, um,
if they, if they wanted to joke about the whole
dumps thing and at SNL was writing room, someone
came up with this fake Giuliani saying this
they would be looked at like what what are you,
ten years old? What are you talking about? A
dump? What do you mean? It doesn't make any
sense. Nobody would believe that. Now, Rudy's
also going to go out and talk about a big dump.
And then here it is. Now, as a reminder, this
all goes back to this infamous historic moment,
historic moment in American political history.
Speaker 2: And what happened if you watched the
election? I was called by the biggest people
saying, congratulations, political people,
congratulations, sir. You just won the
election. It was 10:00. And you looked
at the numbers and I'm sure you felt that way.
This election was over and then they did dumps,
right? They call them dumps, big, massive
dumps in Michigan and Pennsylvania.
Speaker 1: And and Maria BARTIROMO is the eyeglass
adjustment right, when Trump says massive dumps is
still just, I mean, absolutely perfect. So what
is this all about you? I know many of you are
going to be shocked by this all of this stuff
that Rudy's saying, the dumps and everything,
the context is the Hunter Biden laptop story.
I know it's unbelievable. But they're still
talking about Hunter Biden's laptop. So
here is a little more of the Rudy interview.
It's actually interesting to in the middle of
unprecedented legal problems for Donald Trump,
they're talking about the Hunter Biden laptop.
Speaker 3: Mr. Mayor, since when does the FBI
tell a private company like Facebook what
to publish and what not to publish? I mean,
yes, they tell a private company about national
security information. That's a good point.
Wow. I mean, when did that when
when did when did they do that?
That's a very, very good point. Right. Should
security whether or not there's a other
stuff that happens to be about the time that
I was communicating with John Mack Isaacs
and the FBI had seized a year earlier my
it my iCloud account. So here that they're
saying things like there's going to be a big
dump. Hmm. And there was a big dump. Yeah.
I put out the big dump to the New York Post.
Right. But that was a three week period in which
I was communicating with Bob Costello and
John Mack guys. We were going back and forth.
Speaker 1: Imagine trying to follow this.
Speaker 3: And we were doing our own due diligence
to make sure that what he had was legitimate.
Yeah. And then there was a big dump and he
censored it. And you know what? That indicates the
government was part of that. Yeah. That makes all
this First Amendment stuff very different. One of
the ways they get out of the First Amendment is
they say these are private companies. But the
minute the government is conspiring like that,
it's the government violating the First Amendment.
Amazing. Amazing. The FBI reaches out to
Zuckerberg and Facebook goes ahead and throttles
back the story. Twitter. Twitter went even further
and just completely pulled the story. You know,
it's scary. Randall Devine called me before and
corrected that. Oh, she said that Facebook was
the first Twitter followed Facebook. Yeah. I mean,
my Twitter went a little bit for it.
Mr. Mayor, always good to have you on.
We'll talk to you. All right.
Speaker 1: So they're not really
understanding each other, but what's clear is that
Rudy was the source of the dump. And, I mean, it's
this is American politics at this point
in time. Meanwhile, I mean, listen,
I have to tell you, folks, I'm glad to
say that while the second half of the show
has been me catching you up on Rudy's dumping and
Trump's lying on a show no one's heard of, hosted
by Lou Dobbs. And it's just it's almost sad, like
they're in the toilet, for lack of a better term.
It's great that the first half of the show
was look at Joe Biden's achievement on judges.
Look at how the approval rating of Biden
is reacting to material, substantive,
significant accomplishments, including
student loan, student loan debt relief
and the jobs report, the Inflation Reduction
Act, the PACT Act and on and on and on. It's
nice that we have some sanity again
and that we have an approval rating,
at least within some range, responding to the
actions of the president. And it's because I mean,
it's they're in the toilet on the right guys
there in the toilet on the right. And if you
think Rudy's massive dumps are disgusting, look
at what I'm going to talk to you about next